sans avoir été repêché mais à force de
travail et d'acharnement créé ce boucher
est lougansk d'or ont fait leur place
dans la plus grande ligue du monde la
nba pour accueillir monsieur luc
des modèles de persévérance pour la
députée de bourassa-sauvé pour leur
bétail qui tenait à leur remettre la
médaille de l'assemblée nationale à
l'école secondaire calixa lavallée
après une année éprouvante
particulièrement pour les jeunes du
quartier on était dans l'oeil de la
tempête ça a été extrêmement difficile
pour nos jeunes en particulier ici alors
la moindre des choses est de le ramener
lugentz puis crée sport qui parle pour
qui leur parle puis qu'il leur donne un
petit peu d'espoir crise boucher est
lougansk d'or ont grandi dans des
familles modestes du quartier et ont eu
un parcours scolaire cahoteux
aujourd'hui multimillionnaire il martèle
l'importance de s'accrocher à l'école
surtout quand on cherche encore son but
dans la vie j'étais le long qui s'arrête
je veux que vous ça rendra peut-être que
c'est possible si moi je les fait c'est
le gaz la fête c'est possible des fois
y'a mieux des fois y'a permettent chacun
chaque chaque personne alors pro
parcours même moi je vais vraiment
exprimant parcours parce que hinault ce
test est vraiment difficile c'est un
message que les intervenants les parents
pensent souvent sauf que d'avoir une
célébrité une inspiration qui passe un
message là mais ça renforce encore une
fois le message qui est similaire à ce
que les gens de bus scolaires ou
communautaires passe donc d'avoir des
célébrités qui par ce message là il est
important je pense qu'ils ont énormément
reste bouché lugentz d'or sont deux des
trois québécois de la nba avec ken burns
mais ils sont convaincus qu'ils seront
rapidement rejoint par d'autres
surtout si on améliore l'encadrement du
talent local
quand je regardais aux etats unis c'est
vrai que ils ont les ressources plutôt
en attendant ici le temps la focus du
québec mais souvent les ressources pis
ça commence maintenant déjà un autre
talent de montréal-nord frappe aux
portes de la nba bénédicte mathurin
pourraient être repêchés dès le premier
tour en juin prochain ici olivier
paradis le mieux radio canada montréal
nord